sur m6 le camping que la borne feront la
bataille à l'égard du cimetière proche
pour les familles un terrible moment
reconnaître les torts que la chair dans
les bistrots victimes non identifiées et
celui de disparus il ya place première
d'espoir à leurs fins de mois
l'interrogation commence au terrain de
camping at il pu être palliée par la
boue en quelques minutes les orages les
affluents du port de maillots qui
grossit dans le massif des aravis
c'est normal il des précédents en 1872
1956 mais voilà on à la sucrière
le maire salue public que ce camping
privé entre le rapport dit national de
la délégation risque majeur
tout dépend du plan d'exposition
dérogation des contraintes
administratives dans les campings
situation pour sessegnon classable tout
dépendre la préfecture mais les
pressions sont fortes de la part des
élus locaux et des promoteurs
immobiliers de plus évaluer les risques
naturels nécessite des crédits et des
effectifs
ben bernanke le père est resté inachevé
faute de moyens